Les métiers liés au vin sont d'abord ceux
de la production.
Dans les vignes, avec des ouvriers chargés de
l'entretien, plantation, taille, récolte,
jusqu'au chef de culture.
Il y a ensuite la transformation, ça se passera
dans les caves,
avec les cavistes, maîtres de chai ou œnologues.
Et puis enfin la commercialisation, avec l'aide
parfois de négociants ou de courtiers.
Les formations sont accessibles dès la classe
de 3ème pour les CAP et BEP agricoles.
Puis il y a les Bac option vigne et vin,
des BTS, après le Bac,
enfin une formation diplôme national d'œnologie,
ça c'est à l'université,
après une licence scientifique.
Pour en savoir plus dans la région,
je vous invite à vous rapprocher du lycée
viticole de Beaune, la Viti,
ou encore des établissements agricoles de
Davayé en Saône-et-Loire
ou de Cosne-sur-Loire dans la Nièvre,
sans oublier le campus de Dijon pour l’œnologie,
et puis les lycées hôteliers, comme le Castel
à Dijon, pour devenir sommelier.
Enfin, pour vous initier à tous ces métiers,
une bonne façon, ça peut être de participer
aux vendanges.